So now we have what is called
a MOSI coherence protocol.
MS and I are the same as before,
but now there is a new O state.
So the MOSI protocol is like MSI,
except when we are in the M state and
we snoop a read from the other core,
we provide the data as before.
But we now move into the O state,
not the S state.
When we are providing the data,
the memory now doesn't get accessed.
In MSI, the memory would now need
to be written with the data.
Here, we simply provide
the data to the requester,
move to the O state without
updating the memory.
While the block is in
the O state in a cache,
it behaves similarly to the S state,
except that if we snoop a read,
we continue to provide the data
just like we did in the M state.
And that we need to write
the data back to memory,
if the block in the O state
is replaced from that cache.
And that's because all of the other
caches will have the block in either
invalid or shared state, so they don't
know that the block is dirty and
needs to be replaced.
So the M state indicated both that we
have exclusive read/write access to
the block, nobody else has it and
that the block is dirty.
S indicated that we had the shared
read access to the block,
others may also have it in shared
state and that the block is clean.
The memory has an up to date copy.
Now O combines the properties of M and
S states in that it is a shared read
access state, but the block is dirty and
we are responsible for
putting the data in memory and
also because there is only one cache
with the block in the O state.
That cache knows it can respond to
all the read accesses to the data, so
that the memory doesn't.